hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
today i'm going to be answering your
questions that you have been asking me
on instagram on the ground so i'll put a
post up on instagram and i said ask me
anything if you had one question to ask
me what would it be nothing too personal
and some of these questions are personal
so the first question that came in was
are you
genuinely
happy
that's a deep question um so there's a
load of questions in here about money
business so i'm going to go through i'll
read your name and i'll answer your
question i'm going to be doing this
again as well but this time rather than
doing it on instagram i'm going to be
doing it here on youtube so if you've
got a question for me anything at all
around whether it be a personal question
around business finance property
strategy why don't you go ahead right
now comment it below and then next week
on sunday at 7 p.m i will be answering
more property questions more questions
so you go ahead ask a question below and
let's see what we had on instagram last
week so um let's start with um
all right here's another similar one
this is do you believe that money
buys
happiness
there's so many d you instagram folks
are pretty deep today um all right so
i'll answer that one first do i believe
that money buys happiness
i don't think money
buys happiness now i think that
happiness is something that
is more about you as a person your state
of mind and your perspective on life and
so i don't think money buys happiness at
all however i think that money
does buy
choices
so for instance if you have money you
can choose where you live you can choose
to go on holiday or not you can choose
you know your education you can ch money
buys things money buys experiences money
buys freedom money buys choices so i
think that money helps with your
happiness and i think that poverty does
bring misery or it can you know if
you're if you're really poor and you
haven't got enough money to pay the
bills it brings stress and misery and so
poverty can bring misery i don't think
money buys happiness but i think it
helps another thing i'll add to that is
is with money
after about a hundred thousand pounds a
year
i don't think that earning extra money
really affects your day-to-day life so
my life now
i don't think is much different than it
was a year ago or two years ago or three
years ago it's not really that different
and my life in 20 years time or 10 years
time even if i go on to be a billionaire
my day-to-day the house that i live in
the college drive i mean my car i drive
a an autobiography top of the range
range rover i'd personally i wouldn't
want a more expensive car than that and
i don't think even if i did get one i
don't think having a
a
300 000 pounds ferrari would add any
happiness to my life whatsoever so
anyway i'm going to stop waffling on but
that's my answer what do you think
though do you think money buys happiness
let me know in the comments um all right
next question your thoughts on student
accommodation
units
student accommodation units yeah i think
student accommodation units are great um
i i've got some a lot of my students
that have my property students that have
built um apartments for students
that do rent to rent with student
student units
i myself focus more on professional
tenants i think with any strategy if
you're doing for instance hmos
service accommodation if you've got
holiday let's student apartments i think
that just make sure that you've got a
plan b because you never know what could
happen in the future so for instance
during the pandemic when lockdown
happened
students weren't going to uni the unions
were closed so you always need to make
sure that you've got an exit strategy or
a plan b but student units yeah i think
it's a good strategy it's not something
that i'm really focused on but
absolutely it's great if the money
stacks if you buy at the right price i
think it's good
okay what are the characteristics
in a person which makes the biggest
contribution to being successful
i think belief and positivity having a
positive mindset get up and go believing
you can do it being a winner i was just
chatting to a gold medalist athlete a
few hours ago who's one of my students
who's now financially free in property
and he was saying to me that he thinks
that belief and mindset is actually more
important than the technical skills of
property he's become very successful in
property over a short period of time and
he said that all he did was he just took
his or the characteristics of his belief
and of his winning mentality his
mentality he took that from his from
being a gold medalist runner he's a
sprinter he representing england and he
took that and he applied it to property
and he flew so you can read all the
books you can even attend the seminars
you can have all of the information but
if you don't actually believe that you
can do it and if you don't actually have
that get up and go in that positive
mindset then ultimately you're probably
going to struggle in life so i would say
the biggest characteristic is being
positive being focused and having a get
up and go and drive and passion to to
achieve
okay next question oh by the way i
haven't even prepared these questions so
this could this could come out and it
could be something crazy but let's see
um this is uh
i've been doing research and going down
the property investment path is
something i'm keen to begin can you help
me kick start my property investment
journey yes i can number one piece of
advice find someone that's doing what
you want to do and then meet up with
them whether you're meeting them for a
coffee whether you're meeting up with
them on the golf course whether you're
meeting up with them at a networking
event find someone or people or multiple
people that are doing what you want to
do get around them and that's the
biggest advice i can give you if you're
doing this on your own and you're not in
the right environment
environment is stronger than willpower
so that's my advice how do you invest
one million pounds
depends what you want i just invested
one million pounds cash into this house
that i'm sitting in but would i advise
you do that no
um i did that because i just wanted to
buy this house because i wanted to live
in it it was a really smart commercial
move that i'd say everybody should do no
some people
want to build cash flow some people want
to build wealth or preserve wealth so i
think if you've got a million pounds it
would depend on what your goal was um
but if your goal was just to create as
much money as possible with that million
pounds i would probably
recommend putting it into a development
deal maybe buy a commercial building and
turn it into residential apartments
so buy something and push the value up
and then ultimately refinance it
pull the million back out recycle the
cash and then keep the monthly profit of
that investment i think that's probably
what i would recommend you with a
million pounds
if you really make people financially
free i challenge you to do that with me
over a week everyone so far you've done
it with i swear you're already friends
with
um am i friends with them not actually
no that's not true i'm not friends with
them i mean yeah i've just done it with
amelia that was one of my employees
but the previous three so david eccles
and evans and lauter i didn't know them
from adam you know they they applied
onto the eviction and um you know they
they uh that reply and i'd never met
them the first time i met them was when
they applied for the financial freedom
challenge through the eviction um so i
don't i don't just do it with my friends
i do also help my friends become
financially free um if you wanna listen
if you want me to spend a week with you
in your house becoming financially free
you need to do more than just comment on
one of my instagram posts you know you
gotta you gotta
not just me but if you want people to
help you and give you a break here's
something i've learned find a way to get
yourself on their radar okay so if you
want for instance right i wanted to get
on um
grant cardone's radar so what did i do i
flew to miami to one of his events
i paid i went to one of the events and
then i was really interactive and i got
chatting with him one of the breaks i
invited him to do a collab with me we
ended up doing stuff he mentored me
became friends um but i took massive
action i jumped on a plane i spent seven
thousand pounds to go to one of his
events um robert kiyosaki i wanted to
get i read rich dad poor dad i wanted to
get on robert kiyosaki's radar so again
i made big boss moves
to get his attention and then we've
ended up we had we're dinner together um
i hosted an event with him so i think
you just got to make big crazy moves to
get on the right people's radar whether
that's my radar or someone else's radar
um so maybe start just by going to one
of my training programs and and let's
meet and you know that'll be that'll be
a good start
okay um b-o-b b-o-b-a true or false
i don't know what that means dog do you
know what boba means
i don't know what that means i'm really
sorry you're gonna have to enlighten me
on what boba means um plans for the
coming years plans for the coming years
um you know i've made a lot of money in
property uh my plan is to continue doing
that so i'm very actively looking at
sites at the moment development sites
i've got eight sites at the moment and
i'm trying to get that to 10. my goal is
to have it to 10 by the end of 2020 but
i'll probably talk more about that on
another video so yeah i want to build
houses um
develop sites make good money provide
affordable homes for people help with
the shortage of houses
also train as many people as i can and
um and have fun along the way so um
that's that's the big picture of my
goals over the next coming years
um all right what property strategy do
you prefer
me personally it depends on if i'm
starting from scratch my favorite
strategy is probably
deal sourcing packaging deals passing
them on to investors because it's quick
and it's easy and it's fun i love the
adrenaline for me right now i like um
property development i like adding value
to larger houses and last question bum
bum bum which is
are you genuinely happy oh and there's
also another one what time do you set
your alarm eight eight am generally
eight am i'd sleep a lot i generally
sleep for eight hours a night
um are you genuinely happy i am
genuinely happy you know what i love
life i'm very very blessed because not
only have i been successful in business
but i've also been really fortunate with
a beautiful wife and three incredible
children and um i'm healthy and i've got
great friends i'm part of a great church
and i'm a very very very happy person
does that mean that um every day i'm
always happy and everything's always
great of course not everybody has bad
days but i am very very happy and um and
i hope you are too so thank you for
asking so that's it for today
drop your questions in the comment box
and i look forward to reading them and
answering them next week thanks so much
and god bless
[Applause]
[Music]